[Music]
i'm so excited to be here i'm actually
celebrating something tonight i finally
just slept with my high school crush
thank you
thank you but now he like expects me to
go to his graduation
[Laughter]
like i know where i'm going to be in
three years right
slow down
oh kids
kids
tomorrow's my mom's birthday
um no don't clap you don't you don't
know her uh
[Music]
but i'm bringing her to a soccer game
because i wanted to show her what
boundaries looked like you know
look
she's like i don't see him like i know
stop calling my friends
it's just she's always bragging about
the dumbest stuff you know like the
other day she was like you know i can
still fit in my wedding dress it's like
who cares right
i mean it is weird that she's the same
size now
as she was when she was eight months
pregnant but i just
i don't think bragging's right
i don't think it's right
i'm supposed to want kids i don't know
if i do i'm 30. i heard when you're a
girl and you're 30 you're just like i
need a baby but i just don't
want to like make anything with my body
but um
seems creepy but uh
but no i mean i'm 30 years old you know
i think it's because this it's what i do
for a living you know i get drunk every
night
i'm pretty drunk now
thank you but no but the girls i grew up
with they're living normal adult lives
so they call me now and they're like am
i'm pregnant and i'm still like what are
you gonna do
i'm like i'll drive you they're like no
weird
i should like kids that's my favorite
reality show you know the show teen mom
or if you're from the south mom
why wait for a ged that's stupid um
we all judge each other right like i
know as soon as i walked out here you
guys are all like oh she's so beautiful
thank you you guys it's so nice so you
were all thinking that
um
i mean i work really hard but uh
but no we do we judge i've lived in new
york my whole life but people they
always just like assume i'm from the
midwest i've got that look about me
right
it looks like i've milked something
recently right
i know on the subway i'm telling you all
the time people are always like are you
lost i'm like no they're like are you
amish i'm like no
i just like wearing this bonnet like why
are you
it's my fault i look dope in a bonnet i
don't think so
people think i'm shallow but i'm not i
like the guy i'm actually dating right
now he isn't even good-looking
he's not at parties no one's ever like
who's that they're like is he okay
should we call someone i'm like no
that's his face let's just
maybe we should call someone
but i've just never cared about stuff
like that you know looks who cares right
and he's so rich
it doesn't really come up
but no
no okay he's cute he is he looks like
one of the guys from the hills have eyes
it's gross
it's really gross
i can't really talk i i never get hit on
i never do and i know you guys are like
but you're so perfect
stop you guys are so great i can't
believe you guys
no but i don't the only time i get hit
on is last call at the bar right
that's it that's when i'm the belle of
the ball because i have a pulse
it's like the lights go on the men just
start pacing like gorillas
they can only see by heat they're like
what is that it's like predator
see some dude in a full blackout just
starts stumbling toward me like a
toddler learning how to walk
pointing at his crotch like here
like i'll get us a cab
[Music]
[Applause]